so today's topic Johnny Depp if you guys
aren't aware Johnny Depp is an actor in
Hollywood might have seen him Pirates of
the Caribbean
he got X from the role of Captain Jack
Sparrow after he had incidents involving
Amber Heard the two were involved in a
messy divorce in which Amber Heard
alleged that apparently he threw some
hands at her after which basically
Johnny was cancelled by everybody
everyone poured up their support for
Amber Heard so recently some audio came
out this weekend we're gonna take a look
at a conversation that they both
consented to that was recorded this
conversation took place about six months
before the divorce proceedings happen
it's not true I'm not that's different
that's what one does not negate the
other just because I've thrown pots and
pans does not mean that you but I like
how she's saying it like it's not a big
thing listen I know but if we talk
bilasa T of a pot or a pan flying
towards you bro yeah [ __ ] the bands I'm
not getting into the details that fight
you and I both know that you split when
there is no physical and that you do it
and meet like at the very beginning of
fights these days what wait a minute
wait a minute she'll vote for her thing
her whole thing her whole thing and
because when they have an argument he's
but more important it's the language
that she uses she says even when there
is no physical element meaning so she's
basically just admitted to the fence she
did put his hands on him cuz she's
knowing her language is indicating it's
very casual and it's normal even when I
don't he knows he's a man if there's a
fight and the police comes down and he
was in the fight not fighting but in the
fight if the police come down the male
will be taken away oh yeah even if it's
his home his home even if she started a
because it know keep in mind that women
are just as likely to engage any kind of
physical interaction within a
relationship
just as likely if not more so if you
know that that person is like that
what's in it for you to stay there and I
would let you do it and you get dressed
you were screaming that I'm not going to
validate my actions last night
she's good hmm when you accuse me I
swear ah what a flirt QB in Toronto
I'm not start screaming until you poke
an animal enough it is eventually didn't
matter how friendly it is that's where
someone who likes to throw hands let me
tell you something if you put the blame
on the fact that you're physical with
someone on them that is the language of
the oppressor all right you made me do
it
punch me in the face and you said didn't
you talking about
and I want to lie and then I say to you
I'm sorry that I didn't you across the
face enough but I was hitting me who's
not punching you big you're not punched
don't tell me what it feels like to be
punched so now she's gaslighting if you
don't - fighting is is when someone
lives a reality and they're made to feel
almost crazy about it by other people
and mate to think it's all in their head
right that's a common tech that people
will use in order to deflect from the
negative things that they've done to
others and make new people who they've
done those things to think that they're
crazy
I'm not Dec you I who's hitting you you
can I don't know what the motion of my
actual hand was fine and you can imagine
oh this happened right at the time where
she claims that he was always putting
his hands on her that he was terrorizing
her now listening to this conversation
this there's a man who leaves whenever
yelling starts sound like someone who's
constantly putting their hands on you
the language that she's doing the stuff
that she's saying is what society thing
feels and when women are physical with
men right the idea that because women
are physically weaker
man that they have the right to and that
because they don't do is damage that
they have the right to put their hands
on you and I've already brought this up
in another video but I'm like you don't
know what kind of trauma people get been
through you don't know what it happens
to them when you put their hands on them
I know for me personally man or woman
when you tap my face like this
I want to deck just cuz of my past I
can't like just even thinking about it I
get I get robbed up right so I could
imagine that people with a relationship
with more serious stuff they built it
when you put their hands on them you
don't know how they're gonna react just
don't hit people keep your hands to
yourself
if you want to express something use
your words you got words use them does
this how you be talking about man not
being able to express himself express
yourself don't use your fists don't use
your hands
keep your hands to yourself and talk
it's just really funny wait you and your
relationship with trigger you don't talk
with your hands no you really wish they
would know what wouldn't wish I kind of
will do it no no no I wouldn't wish they
would but I'm just saying that is not
something that is possible never ever
I've never seen my parents get physical
not even the thing that that the woman
may call a love tap I would I don't know
what the hell that is
you know this basically it's when you're
okay this doctor I was gonna bring this
up after its when women like get
frustrated with a conversation so they
just like I've never seen we're good we
got it you got it you see that reaction
you have you got that's the reaction I
had bro and so I took this I don't think
there's a trauma but it's just annoying
I've never seen my parents do that my
girl never did that I never did that at
my girl we don't we don't even scream we
don't scream yeah no yeah after an
argument you don't don't scream that
[ __ ] you could go find some some aid
mm-hmm you better come you better calm
down you better call Tyrone
hmm you can't use my phone
do you think that the eyes of man when I
get frustrated with my male friends that
I put my hands on them when in the
middle of a heated conversation
I've never cuz you know might ensue
right because we understand that between
men we don't put them we don't we don't
play like that
so just it blows my mind and you see how
comfortable she is and she does
something to a heightened degree where
she's closed fist and she's trying to
dislike the person afterwards is it go
fights yes you did she did the right
thing the big thing you know you're
admirable you know even when he does a
big thing he's Phillip he tried to stay
there he gets dipped in the mouth well
you didn't really get bit and you're
fine did you he leaves oh okay you're
America you're the big person he can't
win he that is a lose-lose situation
right there may be excuses that he knows
it might escalate into so to go fine it
sounds like you guys do this so often
that that's why he doesn't want to be
around for those conversations you know
where it starts it starts with yelling
and it starts with something else and so
you want to avoid the genesis of those
kind of situations you you you leave the
situation you know like don't walk away
from me do it again it's his
responsibility that she's like to help
me save me yeah but you didn't help me
it's a crazy man I would have not
tolerated a single word from this broad
it's just crazy to me that a really
famous dude like this will go this far
but then you realize they say you got
nothing to do with that this is this
touches people on every income level
every status level but I would never
major if things get physical we have to
separate yeah I'll give you part whether
it's for a [ __ ] an hour or ten hours
or [ __ ] a day you must there can be
no physical violence I can't see what
happens when you hashtag believe her she
finally managed II you silence you
ostracize and you push people to the
brink who are actually innocent because
you have this blanket idea you don't
need factual proof in order to condemn
people this is unbelievable man you
listen to this audio and it's clear
what's going on it's obvious keep in
mind this is a conversation they both
consented to having recorded because
they just want to talk and you know what
this this is out now what okay the
reason why this is out now we're hearing
about this now it's because they had the
divorce she didn't want to get divorced
right she didn't want that because she
worked so hard for the wedding
you know the image of the wedding and
everything and stuff they get a divorce
she's not happy he has money is like you
know what it is gonna be what its gonna
be
it's okay talk to Amber and I ain't you
know what let's never talk about this
again because everywhere in the tabloids
it's ruining my reputation it's ruining
everything it's not tonight our business
now don't need to doesn't need to be out
there don't talk a word about us I will
talk the word about us and let's leave
it at that and keep it going
she spoke words of that and went back
again and anyone like okay you wanna
play okay and then he put that hit that
[ __ ] out couple days ago in she was a
big speaker at the women's March in Los
Angeles and you come to find out she's
the oppressor we got married I thought
maybe that's where he messed up listen
you guys if you have a problem and
you're gonna marry yourself you think
that problem go away because you have
you're gonna get married or you're gonna
have children or you're gonna buy a
house a boat a [ __ ] chew up hey it's
the opposite
even the chia pet won't save you yeah
all right because the reality is once
you have that secured and you know that
other person is not gonna leave you're
actually more likely to exhibit all the
behaviors that you're not used to you
know you're less likely to do it in a
relationship because a person can leave
at any point once their marriage they're
tied to you so you can engage it
whatever behavior because you have to
maintain this facade of a perfect
relationship and on top of that it
doesn't solve anything I mean it just
adds more pressure yep it just adds more
pressure so if you were having more
pressure than you had before and you was
fighting before
chances are you gonna fight more because
of more pressure yep people understand
that early on in a relationship they
might lose their partners so they hide a
lot of their behavior right because they
know the person is not fully invested I
mean when you like doing business when
you do business with another company
you're gonna send your best employee
this is the best employee represent all
the cuts all the employees no use just
your best chances doing business with
that other company and that's pretty
much it
and you send your best employee but one
day when you get in a relationship with
that company the best employee is gonna
have to go on vacation and the rest of
the employees gonna sue and then you
don't see the real deal of the company
Johnny's not here not Johnny's not here
y'all break my name Rick are you doing
I'll take care of you and then you see
the real thing the real company the rest
of the employees in an effort to be woke
a lot of these you know woke to fists
whoa yes a lot of these woke tourists
whoa like you guys understand the point
that where he was that with his life
what if he's taking his own life
all you people ikely because you don't
you don't lose a lot of money you lose
most to your work everybody
hasta sighs you you can't go on public
anymore how do you think that treats
thank God he had the tape cause if you
wouldn't have the tape nobody's really
like that nobody's really gonna go out
of their way to like yes you telling me
an actor someone happened personally
impersonate someone else for for their
work
it's not gonna be able to do it in real
life it's not gonna be able to lie to
have a certain kind of advantage people
do it all the time I already said this
in another video but like guard no
shelters for men who are hit there are
no resources for us one these kind of
things happen almost every man I can
think of can honestly say that in his
relationships he's had women put their
hands on them physically every single
one but then if I ask the opposite it's
not all women because in our society we
allow women to showcase their
frustration and their aggression
physically without any repercussions and
if men complain were seen as weak we're
seeing grow up Johnny baby right her
words to me weren't even her words it
was society's words pretty much telling
men you what happens to you imagine like
your man you go to a patient they're
gonna wait until something really
happens to her yeah to be honest with
you yeah if that happened they're gonna
be like well leave it's like that great
leave I I've seen it man I've seen it so
often where women are that comfortable
putting their hands on people
I work in bars the number of girls that
had to remove from the bar because
they're the most problem does not equate
the number of guy I had to be wound from
a bar guys wanna fight yeah girls fight
girl fights guys I'm sorry guys fight
guys yeah a woman two girls fight guys
and girls
a woman can put her hands on him in a
hundred times and if the man retaliates
once he's the devil
15 either do you understand how much
patience that require sometimes when I
look there's nothing wrong with walking
away when there's a fight oh no listen
I've done it before
plenty of time I've done it there's even
a long video of me on this channel where
a woman became very belligerent I have
my own a little incident would you guys
can go watch your your your and I was
very patient she was putting her hands
on me
she was screaming at the top of her
lungs and I was like yeah listen you
gotta you gotta bounce
you got a leaf right now you gotta go
and she just kept going and going and
going it didn't care you know it didn't
care and of course she doesn't care
because she knows there's no there's no
consequences for what she does so she
permit I could never even though I would
is hurting even though all the stuff was
happening I had to sit there and take it
and I'm like so I know exactly what he's
gone through and the best thing you can
do is walk away not do anything because
even though she deserves to get equal
rights and equal left's even though she
deserves it
sometimes you got to be smart
before being right or left because I
could have given her that and I would
have given her a little bit of sense of
justice but then I'm in jail I have a
criminal record
I can't travel anymore my whole careers
derailed all because I retaliated a
justified situation because you know
they're gonna believe her so then women
who could be like why do you need a
men's rights activist movement I didn't
get it before I get it now you know so
anyways I think that pretty much touches
all my points that I want to touch on
what do you want to say about women were
physical and stuff that was very rude
sister to have to ask for it sounds very
rude with the sounds for proof but it's
the only thing that we have rightt
and wouldn't it been for those tapes
those recordings it would be cancelled
and a lot of people that I was talking
to were like yeah now I believe her I
believe I believe them
I believe in I never believed her once
yeah okay he does it doesn't matter some
of you must be lying because he ain't
got no job yeah I mean some of you must
be lying because he was not no movies it
was canceled it's like saying hey nobody
likes rocks some of you align because
that's a billion-dollar industry right
there crocks shoes
some of you like Crocs okay not all the
you can they like yeah you know what we
don't like rocks the early note some you
[ __ ] the lion they make money
okay same thing here and so you see the
same thing that led to her being
believed is the same thing that led to
kill be brights accuser being believed
right you guys are willing to tarnish
anybody just because someone says some
stuff regardless of what the heaven is
like because it fits your narrative and
that's what I'm saying I'm not trying to
go from our narrative or anybody's
narrative I'm like where's the proof if
there's no
proof don't bring me the story because I
don't have all the elements I can't give
you a judgment on something I don't
understand the scope of it's like trying
to build a house on man you haven't
surveyed it's like Bill it's like it's
like trying to cook a meal with
ingredients you don't know about good
luck
let me go put that ghost pepper in my
oatmeal you gonna learn today here it is
so it's by incredibly average he's a
small youtuber and he's actually covered
a previous incident in which in a
deposition amber was locked I was caught
lying about how physical she's been with
Johnny Depp so if you guys go incredibly
average he's a small youtuber but he's
done quality work he's really done a
great job it's almost an hour the audio
that he had but if you want more
information once through the full
context just to know that we didn't edit
it go check them go thank you from our
word just go watch it yourself and be
sure to subscribe
[Music]
you're still being admirable right just
like running away and you can see hurry
and call me names but you could call the
name or what do you do that's the last
insult you're a baby you are a prick you
don't do anything that you actually do
you expect from people you can't give
them but this seems to be the day
following the incident I covered in this
video on which amber admitted in her
2016 deposition to pushing her way into
the bathroom where Johnnie was hiding
from her and in his attempts to keep her
out the door scrape her toes and when he
leaned down to check she kicked the door
into his head and punched him in the
face I have not done this to you I have
not said these things to you I have not
started to fight by saying I'm shaving
in the room I'm not gonna sit here and
fight about Toronto anymore guess what
I'd let it go I'm not talking about
Toronto I think me the tapes
I can't whisper it I can write it guess
what it's a sick and tired I'm fighting
about old fight this is not about a
fight this is wrong this is a broad
thing and if I'm telling you every
single time you get dressed
and you [ __ ] split the top of a fight
you never be trying to work it out
never fight for me you never come to me
you never self com you never self sooth
you remember the one to throw the olive
branch I'm sick and tired of it it needs
to change but every time you don't like
what I say and you can run away we'll
never work out anything you can't run
away every fight you can't it's easy
it's not brave it's not strong it's
harder to say to somebody I want to work
this out I want to face what I have I
want to face what you have I want to
work it out with you you're not working
it out you don't fight for me
you don't fight when there's a problem
you don't come to me you don't make
peace with me you never extend an olive
branch you're never the bigger guy
you're never the one that's like okay
I'm gonna put my own feelings aside for
a second and say this is bigger than us
let's stop fighting
you never are the one to come and knock
on my door what because I
no because I wanted to have us didn't
interrupt you you asked me right you
said right I met you interjected I met
you said you said how about that email
is this better I answered you I dressed
what you're saying now can we please not
fight about that can we please not fight
about that
oh you how about we talk about that Wow
you brought that [ __ ] back man make a
video about that make a video about that
why don't you make a video about that
why don't you make a video about that do
you see any similarities oh it's a
narcissistic behavior everything I speak
about is important everything you want
to speak about till we not talk about
that yeah let's just talk about this